Fans have been waiting years to find out which
new twists would be added to the story by
the new creative team for the rebooted Hellboy
franchise.
We're gritting our teeth, dusting off our
tomes of BPRD history, and casting a spell
of blood magic to bring you all the small
details you missed in the 2019 version of
Hellboy.
Hellboy starts the movie heading to Mexico
to find a missing B.P.R.D. agent and close
friend, Esteban.
He finds his old pal wrestling in a lucha
libre arena under the name Camazotz, seemingly
indifferent to Hellboy's concern.
In the comic storyline Hellboy in Mexico,
Hellboy teams up with a group of 1950s luchadores
while fighting vampires in Mexico.
After a night of heavy drinking, one of the
brothers, Esteban, wanders out into the night
and gets turned into a vampiric luchador called
Camazotz.
The movie closely follows the storyline, as
Hellboy is forced to battle against the giant
bat creature, impaling him on a ring post.
The movie even includes the months-long drinking
bender that Hellboy goes on afterwards.
When Hellboy gets picked up by B.P.R.D. agents
in Mexico, Professor Broom lets him know he
has to go to the Osiris Club to help them
out with a giant problem that they're having.
"The British occult society born in 1866 by
the ranking members of the Heliopic Brotherhood
of Ra."
“Ra?”
In the comics, the Heliopic Brotherhood is
a group of supernatural-obsessed cultists
who went around causing trouble.
They usually battled against Sir Edward Grey,
the Witchfinder, a Victorian-era precursor
to latter-day heroes like Lobster Johnson
and Hellboy.
The Brotherhood's reference in the film isn't
just to show that the new film is firmly enmeshed
within the larger Hellboy comics universe.
It's also a sly bit of foreshadowing to the
Osiris Club's betrayal of Hellboy while on
the Wild Hunt.
If you've got a phobia of eye trauma, stay
away from this movie.
Hellboy himself blinds at least three different
monsters on-screen.
Plus, there's Baba Yaga, the witch who lost
one eye to Hellboy before the movie's events.
She's eager to pop one of Big Red's yellow
eyes into her socket.
She offers Hellboy a deal for information
on Nimue the Blood Queen's next move in return
for one of his eyes.
Hellboy accepts, but ends up reneging on the
deal, telling the witch that she can have
the eye when he's done with it.
That might not have been the right decision.
He gets hit with a nasty curse and ends up
losing out on some knowledge.
Hellboy probably should have remembered the
Norse myth of Odin, who is said to have traded
an eye for divine wisdom.
Hellboy is able to get out of the trade with
Baba Yaga by telling the witch that she never
specified a time frame to collect his eye.
It's a savvy trick that gives our hero the
high ground for not staying true to his word
when making a deal with a child-killing cannibal
witch, and it also subtly connects Hellboy
to Nimue.
A significant portion of the film is devoted
to Hellboy struggling with his dual loyalties
to humanity - epitomized by Professor Broom
- and monsterdom, represented by Nimue.
She tells him that they're bound by fate.
That might be true, but they're also bound
by how tricky they both are.
After Gruagach defeats Hellboy in combat,
Nimue takes the former's power away.
When Gruagach reminds Nimue that she promised
to "make him whole," she responds that she
did.
She just didn't tell him for how long.
Nimue and Hellboy's dual trickery connects
the two characters.
When Hellboy leaves her house with both his
eyes, Baba Yaga curses him that he'll use
both of his eyes to see the one person he
loves most in the world suffer and die.
Later in the film, Alice is hit by one of
Nimue's poisonous needles, and her outlook
seems grim.
With Alice knocking on Heaven's door, it seems
like the film is setting her up to be the
unfortunate recipient of Baba Yaga's curse.
But all she needed was a little Merlin magic
to get back up on her feet.
The curse's real target seems to be Professor
Broom, who Nimue kills while Hellboy watches.
The Wild Hunt is another element of the movie
straight out of European myths.
There are many, many variations of the myth,
but one of the most consistent aspects of
the Hunt is that it presages an outbreak of
war or plague.
The Wild Hunt of Hellboy is a bit distinct
in that everyone involved in the Hunt, except
for Hellboy, is a normal human.
Nimue is known for bringing with her plagues
and destruction, and there are definitely
enough demons and soldiers milling about in
the final scenes to qualify as a war.
One of the most memorable lines is when Hellboy
rebuffs Nimue's offer of romantic alliance
by telling her that,
"This is not gonna work, ya know, cuz I’m
a Capricorn and you're f---ing nuts!"
It's not actually accurate, though.
In the comics, Hellboy's given birthday is
October 5, which would make him a Libra.
It's easy to see why screenwriter Andrew Cosby
went with the Capricorn; the zodiac symbol
is a goat.
Hellboy's demon father takes the form of a
goat, occasionally, and Hellboy's horns are
goat-like.
One of the Huntsmen asks Hellboy what his
rocky right hand is used for.
"It smashes things real good."
That line might have come as a shock to super
fans of the comics and 2004's Hellboy, since
they know that Hellboy's "Right Hand of Doom"
is the key to controlling the Ogdru-Jahad,
Lovecraftian creatures from beyond space and
time.
None of that plays into 2019's Hellboy, largely
because his space-worm controlling stone hand
isn't part of the movie's doomsday prophecies.
It's more of a battle between his demonic
evil and Arthurian good twin heritages, with
the forces of evil kept decidedly in the folklore
and hellish realms.
While Hellboy's appearance on a small Scottish
island after a Nazi ritual is kept fairly
faithful to the original comics, there is
one noticeable twist.
In the original comic, the Torch of Liberty,
a creation of John Byrne's that was loaned
to Mike Mignola on a one-time basis, is there.
Since the character figured so prominently
in Hellboy's origin, you'd expect him to make
another appearance, but due to copyright issues,
Mignola has steered away from ever reusing
the Torch.
In the movie, the pulp hero who's there is
Lobster Johnson.
Whenever Mignola and his collaborators needed
to use a pulp hero to fight Nazis in the Hellboy
universe, they used the Lobster.
Making him an official witness to Hellboy's
arrival on Earth is a pretty declarative statement
that the film takes place within that larger
universe.
More importantly, they kept his catchphrase:
"Beware my claw, for I've come to inflict
justice!"
The filmmakers are clearly trying to reboot
the Hellboy franchise with this movie, and
they wanted to avoid audiences confusing it
for a sequel, so a lot of familiar faces from
the previous films don't appear.
Yet if the ending of the film is any indication,
they knew that they could only get in one
movie without Hellboy's good friend Abe Sapien.
"Hey, Abe!"
Played by Doug Jones in Hellboy and Hellboy
II: The Golden Army, Abe Sapien is an icthyo
sapien, a more humanoid Creature from the
Black Lagoon.
The closing scene of 2019's Hellboy features
Hellboy, Alice, and Ben Daimio raiding a warehouse
in Siberia with a tank that reads "Icthyo
Sapien."
If the film ends up earning a sequel, it's
a sure bet Abe will appear.
Hellboy's post-credits scene finds the half-demon
getting prodigiously drunk at his father's
grave, only to be interrupted by the Lobster's
ghost.
Hellboy geeks out at meeting his childhood
hero, and the Lobster gives a stirring pep
talk to get Hellboy back on his feet.
If there's one thing that Hellboy loves doing,
it's getting drunk with ghosts.
"Oi!
I need some ID, love."
"Are you serious?"
In fact, that's how The Wild Hunt storyline
in the comics starts.
Hellboy's called to lead the Hunt after going
on a boozy tour of Great Britain's finest
ghost houses.
Some character beats are simply too important
for any adaptation to ignore.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about superhero
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.